وعدنا من قبل الروس بانهم سيفعلون كل ما
يمكنهم فعله لوقف الانتهاكات التي تحدث في
وادي برده والمناطق الاخرى اذا توقفت
الانتهاكات واذا توقف النظام عن مداهمه
وادي برده والمناطق المحاصره مثل محج
ودرعا فنحن سنحضر اي مرحله
مقبله منذ البدايه قلت انني لا اعتقد ان
النظام او حتى ايران اراد وقف اطلاق النار
لان هذه هي الطريقه الوحيده التي يمكنهم
فيها الاستمرار بمهمه المناطق وتنفيذ
عمليات التطهير العرقي المنظمه
هذه قلنا ذلك مرات عديده نحن نعتقد بالحل
السياسي الحل العسكري لن ينجح في سوريا هو
غير ممكن في
سوريا نتمنى ان يلتزم الروس بوعودهم هذه
المره سمعنا الكثير من الوعود ونحن ننتظر
لنرى ماذا سيحدث على ارض
الواقع بالتاكيد عندما يكون هناك اكثر من
62 ميليشيا جهاديه تقاتل من اجل ايران على
الارض السوريه فنحن نعتبر غزات هم يحتلون
بلادنا ويشردون شعبنا ليس من الممكن ان
تكون ايران جزء من الحل نحتاج الى خروج
هذه الميليشيات وهذا جزء من الاتفاق هذا
جزء من اليه وقف اطلاق
النار نعم بعد سبعه ايام سنحصل على رد حول
ورقه وقف اطلاق النار سنرى في السبعه ايام
المقبله ما اذا كان النظام او ميليشياته
سيستمرون بانتهاك وقف اطلاق النار اذ ما
زالت هناك مناطق محاصره ومعظم القوات
والميليشيات مدعومه من ايران لذلك نحن
ننتظر لنرى ما الذي سيحدث على ارض الوا
وما الذي سيحدث في
الحقيقه لقد وعدنا باطلاق سراح السجناء من
النساء الروس وعدو بانهم سيساعدون في
الافراج عن السجينات
هناك انباء والان انتم تعرفون هناك بعض
الاشتباكات بيننا وبين النصره في شمال
سوريا لكننا لن نتحدث عن النصره ما لم
نحقق خروج الميليشيات او المقاتلين
الاجانب من سوريا هذا هو السبيل الوحيد
الذي يمكننا من تهيئه الاجواء لوقف
الارهاب في سوريا ودون خروج الميليشيات
والمقاتلين الاجانب فمن الصعب جدا جعل
سوريا مكانا غير جاذبا للمقاتلين الاجانب
القتال